if i'm thinking two steps down the road
and i'm kind of like understanding the
human nature of how we work
and our desire for growing and a desire
for a better tomorrow and
and the awesome things about capitalism
there are also some downsides
we're only measuring what we produce but
in a way that we never measure what's
going on around us
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
today i learned that following your
passion is is not a momentary thing it's
not
a current job it's it's a philosophy
it's a way of life
it's something that you take on with
many many years of hard work
because if that really is your passion
you just can't do anything else
and today i met with michael maluel the
ceo of share it and
he pretty much embodies that exact idea
michael swam for 20 years his life
holding a national swimming record for
18 years to this date
including israel's athlete of the year
of 2007 by maarev
he studied in swamp for georgia
institute of technology in the states
spent the last 11 years leading design
and development of products using mobile
technology for startups and fortune 500
companies
he is the father of two amazing kids
married to hen and lives in tel aviv
meet michael michael malouk welcome to
20 minute leaders
how are you today i am very well
good morning how are you michael good
morning
i am fantastic i'm speaking to the 2007
israel athlete of the year it is a
pretty pretty incredible honor
it's really amazing yeah it was uh
awesome times
in the 20 years of swimming career had a
chance to spend uh
travel the world compete and all of
those uh
events were in 2007 and so
today you're the ceo of sherry
previously where the
the chief operating officer a
peer-to-peer marketplace
for second-hand items but but before we
dive into you know the tech world and
all that boring stuff
and i'm just kidding of course but i
because the talking about 20 years of
swimming career
it is so rare that i get to talk to
somebody about that and hear about their
experiences
and it goes back all the way to kentucky
right
tell me about that so yeah they actually
university of kentucky was the first
place i
uh i uh started college in
i um looked for a great swimming team
and um kentucky was one of them they
were ranked high in the ncaas and uh
i got a scholarship and flew over there
um
i didn't know so much about the us i was
expecting some uh bigger buildings you
know type of new york style and uh
i arrived and the first thing you see is
a horse running
next to you and uh huge places farms and
uh i was looking for those big buildings
for about a year i never found them
there but i found some amazing place
amazing people it is a completely
different atmosphere and
i really enjoyed my time there it was a
huge
learning curve from the beginning
through the time i moved to georgia tech
and it was all pleasure
and so georgia tech obviously is one of
the most prestigious
universities in the world especially if
we're if we're talking about high tech
what is it what is it like being a
student athlete
swimming at a place like georgia tech oh
both in tech and in kentucky's being a
student athlete
is uh is uh a busy schedule
busy but fulfilling um you wake up uh
pretty much every other actually four
days a week you wake up
at 5 15 a.m you head out to practice
actually in kentucky it was
even more amazing because when you wake
up in the winter
you go out in like 12 15 degrees
fahrenheit
which is uh minus 12 celsius or so
and i took my bicycles and then i
found all the black eyes you could you
could imagine and just skid over
um to the practice so
then when you get to practice you get a
chance to make it even better
and you jump into a cold pool so just in
case you haven't felt
the entire thing so uh in case you
haven't
been in hypothermia yet you'll get a
chance to now fully exactly but you know
the funny thing is the motivation is so
high
to push as hard and to be as best as you
can you don't really
think about it you just take it for
granted and you keep on doing it again
and again and again
and that was my life since i'm like 13.
i didn't know anything else i thought
that's
that's how it goes and i couldn't miss a
practice you don't allow yourself to
miss a practice and
you go on one step after another
and you get things done but but it
sounds like it's not just you know
a historical part of you as a swimmer
because
you bike all the time i believe you like
more than 90 or 98
of of your commute in general yes
go ahead you're correct um
bicycles have something else that
awesome about them
they avoid traffic so
using bicycles was um was also
it started from two uh uh from two
aspects the first one
i just really didn't wanna be bounded to
the traffic jams and to the fact that i
go out and i never know where when i'm
coming in
so i started to bike and in the
beginning i was biking of one hour every
every direction but i knew that when i
left israel i got into
and over time i actually found another
advantage which is
really in my own mind and for myself i
did well with the environment which made
me feel better
um and that's it since 2013 i've been
spending pretty much all of my commute
using bicycles i do have a car it is
nicely looking in the parking spot
um but beside that it doesn't do
anything much
but that's it i i think that you know i
got so used to
the habit of driving and getting you
know being so dependent on ways and all
of a sudden when i
moved to to the heart of tel aviv and
i'm biking places and i know exactly how
long it's going to take me to get from
place to place and i get there and i
feel good i'm not stressed i can breathe
i can you know plan accordingly and and
i think that it's it's it's amazing and
i just wait for
you know 10 15 years down the line when
when that's just going to be the
mainstream
in whatever capacity and both of
both the swimming and the bikings you
know the teamwork of the swimming
and the biking which is also a very much
a collaborative
nature type of activity i'm feeling it's
quite
you know it's part of a larger idea that
we do things you know not just for us
but for the world and for others
brings me a little bit to share it
because that the mission there also
feels a little bit in line with you know
the way that you've been
living yourself uh with the brief that i
got to know you already
tell me a little bit about you know your
entrance to the tech world
and and now being the ceo of share it
so my interest to the tech world
actually happened when i was about
six or seven or so my dad gave me
an old piece of equipment
and and i was always looking to break
them down and
and see what's inside and trying to
bring it back together i was extremely
good in breaking it down and see what it
what's inside but on the bringing it
together i had some difficulties
once in a while so that was my first
initiative with technologies
from that point on i was always excited
to see the first vcr
it's like we've been i've been here for
a moment you realize when you're talking
about vcrs
you realize you've been here for a
moment or two in the in this planet
and from that point the first digital
camera i was
i was living in a boarding school in
wingate actually since i was 16 i uh
wow i left that i left my house and um
and
joined a group of other swimmers and we
all lived together
and i had the first digital camera it
was unique it was amazing
and it kept on going i had cameras with
me all over the place i had the first
laptop and
and over time i found myself starting to
building websites i
i um was i'm gonna shut this
down okay i apologize
it's part of the beauty that we're doing
this remotely that we
you know it's so weird that we get to
know you know i mean i'm sort of in your
house you're in my house it's really
cool
continue all right so apologies so
i uh i ended up spending time in trying
to understand how to build websites and
then i
wanted to understand how do you how do
you advertise in this
tool called google and and over time i
kind of like so i realized that when you
build websites you got to do
uh something like old design in
photoshop and then one thing led to the
other
and what you end up doing is one every
question really leads you into the next
thing
and every time it opens up a bit more so
um
my i guess that that my engagement will
with technology always re uh resulted
from the core of i wanted to
get to to understand how that work and
really how that work
is a set of many things that work
together so and i kind of like put
myself as a
hands-on person from the very beginning
and
eventually led me to open a company and
the company
was really providing software solutions
at the beginning we were building
technologies
myself in a an amazing partner i had uh
errors and we we actually started that
in the states in atlanta
um small startups at the beginning
mobile technology at first
already in 2011 we were fairly unique in
our ability to design and develop
mobile technologies but over time we
ended up going out
the iphone was only four or five years
old i believe
about three years old really um 2008 if
i remember correctly
was uh the first iphone and the
softwares and really got into kik
um i had the privilege to work in home
depot and get exposed to mobile
technologies
sooner than later and i also worked with
india a lot actually that was my main
capacities um the same thing actually i
flew to india i opened an office there
in jaipur
it worked well then it worked amazing so
uh flew there again
this time we took pune and opened
another office and using that
over time we kind of like explored we
started to give services
we grown up to uh we
we won some interesting beats and
develop some interesting technologies of
companies that have done exits
um but also for fortune 500 companies
we we really put ourselves out there and
i think we got some people be happy and
recommend us
um but over time as we have been
successful and we as we started to go
out for companies and explore what's the
user flow do you think this is what you
need
let us let us take a look let us
actually go outside talk to people
which is really the only way to really
know if you're developing a solution
that
fits the actual needs and not what you
imagine
our eyes we learned fairly early on that
our eyes
are really a deceiving uh tool they're
problematic because we see what we see
and what we see is really what not what
we need to see we need to see what they
see
so uh we've done that and we went
outside we explored
um but there was another urge in me i
saw one time i actually took a trip to
florida
and in florida interestingly enough i
went out
for a dive to look for coral reefs but
you know what i saw
michael dead coral reefs
but then i asked myself but wait aren't
we supposed to see coral reefs
said yes those are the coral reefs so
but it doesn't look like it i saw it in
the
national geographic looks more alive
said yeah
it didn't you know last year it doesn't
work well so i went in and checked
what i saw was fairly sad in the 1980s
they were alive so what happened so i
went in and researched
and like happened to the same thing that
happened to me in technologies
happened when i tried to explore what
happened to us in the planet
as humans what are we setting up
ourselves for the next generations what
are my kids gonna grow up into
i didn't have kids at that time but i
thought about it i said hello
that's actually if i'm thinking two
steps down the road and
i'm kind of like understanding the human
nature of how we work
and our desire for growing and a desire
for a better tomorrow and
and the awesome things about capitalism
there are also some downsides
we're only measuring what we produce but
in a way that we never measure what's
going on around us
so exploitation and then i understood
the air
the air uh situation around us the water
pollution
that we create the abusing of multiple
things and
and suddenly what i realized
i see this awesome dog you should meet
milo's one day
um it's a carpet it's not a real dog
so when you when you swim
when you do personal sports mostly which
are usually not involving uh
getting a huge lump of uh money or being
rich at the end of it
you coming directly from your heart you
have passions you have a drive you wait
i specifically
i had 14 practices every week
for one main competition a year which
really if i was like
20 hundreds of a second better i was
making a party as if i don't know what
happened
but you know 20 hundreds of a second
better meant potentially
almost a european record you know or
being first
versus eight so it all down to the wire
so you got to be
super you got to be you got to give it
all in every single moment
and i when i did contracting work
you have this passion you learn you you
get to know people but eventually get to
a point where
things have been done you know you got a
contract you you run through that you do
service and all all that happens is you
do it again it's interesting to see more
companies
but the firing side had
good amount of percentage resulted out
of monetary or
money reasons um but this
situation on the planet this situation
of the environment was burning inside
and when i listened to it
i was excited after i got
slightly depressed from what i saw you
know uh when you realize what's
happening in the world when you're
connected to
to us as humans and the nature of us you
can
understand we're in a bit of a pickle we
have an issue
we have a challenge it's a nice way to
put it i didn't say many challenges and
i didn't say that they are
extremely tough but uh we're looking at
something significant for all of us to
to do so i started to look again and i
started to research i started to talk to
people
and i started to look for things that
are new
and what i found
is that i am actually excited to give
all of my skills and all of my life and
time towards that mission and be part of
the movement
that is saying we want to change we want
to do something that when we do benefits
when we give
value around us things are happy
things are better off in sherry's case
when we
talk about sherry there are two
interesting benefits to it
one of them is like we spoke about the
environment
any second-hand marketplace actually is
benefiting the environment
sheridan has two more interesting
aspects because
we insure it you get things for points
you you can actually i can uh get your
awesome uh uh
what is that a roomba four points or
anything
that you might wanna upload there that
it allows us to reduce stress because we
don't have money we're not negotiating
it's all
easy but it also allows us and that
creates relationships that are awesome
but on top of it what we really saw is
that when you deal with points
you expose a long tail of items and then
when i
realize what i'm seeing because when you
think about it when you sell one car
which is not sold in sherid by the way
how many books you have how many beauty
stuff you have for that one card
how many impulse buys you have in malls
online alibaba god knows what that are
really stuck in your home
you see this nice planter see that
not likely you're gonna sell that in any
second hand place it's not going to be
but insure it you can
all the stuff are actually being sold in
shared so
we are going into the long tail just to
give you perspective
that it's perceived i have i have just
read
uh some articles they're saying that the
size of
the second hand market is 400 billion or
really shortly gonna be expected to be
400 billion
but the amount of things we have at home
is 4.5 trillion
so why are those things it is tons of
clothing
tons of beauty stuff tons of books and
tons of
hardware kitchen actually diy stuff
what about just a wood that is sitting
down next to me that i can renovate
so share it is really opened itself up
to expose that and how do we do that
it's so simple that it's almost stupid
we create another wallet that is
debt-free and that wallet is points it's
not connected to your guess not
connected to your rent
not connected to anything you want to do
but you can still get things with it
without spending any money and really
when we're looking at it we actually had
a very interesting uh
conversation with a japanese campaign
company in japan is the capital of
points capital of community currencies
they're really excited to see what we're
doing and what we're exposing
and um i would like to say that we are
significantly leading the world in how
we are
looking how we're managing that only in
december 10 this was the first time we
set up to the uh we said to the world
we're here please use it give us give us
some feedback
tell us how it looks like what do you
feel so um
and since then we saw some unbelievable
things the speed of how things are
moving
is unbelievable to give you perspective
an active person would trade about 30
items
would exchange from actually would just
get
30 items a month on average and would
upload once a day
it's free it's fun exchanging became fun
so this whole thing has kind of like put
me in a place where
i can do well while doing good
which combines my history of being able
to um
to work in a monetary in a in a normal
way where
actually you bring value you create
normal companies
we are a for-profit company uh we're not
a foundation
but while we do that we're aiming to do
extremely well for economy
people planet
i love that if sheriff succeeds the
planet succeeds and i can't find
you know a better alignment than that
and i think that you know i i just love
how it ties
back to your own journey and you know
your own experiences whether it's in
in swimming or in cycling or you know
all across the board and and i think
it's a
it's just pretty inspiring especially
the aspect of
of finding something that you're truly
passionate about and you want to
dedicate to
and then you're finding and you're
spending meaningful time with yourself
for
also finding those solutions but but
really being intentional about it and i
think this intentionality is what i get
most inspired by
in these conversations michael thank you
so much for coming here i really really
appreciate it
i have a few more questions for you are
you ready i am ready
i think that i'm as ready as i can be
michael
there you go okay we'll start off easy
your favorite
subject in school k to 12.
my fav okay please repeat the question
my favorite subject in school and then
you're cut off
please k-12
what is kindergarten 12th grade oh
k to 12 then uh
it is uh wow i don't know even how to
say it in english it was
the word in hebrew is malacha but
or in sports that was the easy one in
college i actually got connected more to
the emerging technologies
which was my favorite course and i did
actually three of those almost
i found it fascinating wow
georgia tech okay i can't expect
anything else uh
one of your role models somebody that
you look up to wow wow wow
this is a good question generally when i
when i look for role models there are
two things that i'm i'm
um pointing at a balanced and in a war
person
um or i
feel that at the beginning of my life i
looked at elon musk as emerging
technology
but then lately bought too many bitcoins
pollutes the world
but uh i am in a full understanding
it is a hard one to immediately answer
but i'm gonna look for people that are
conscious that are balanced
in their approach that are not being led
by
emotions or by what some call
their survival instincts
i love that i i think that's one of the
best answers to this question that i
received
and the last one is three words you
would choose to describe yourself
so i think that the basics of uh
what i've done in life was associated
with being tenacious
um and motivated together
those uh two are making my life uh
extremely interesting in times i am not
a person who's willing to let go i
think that i'll define myself as a going
all out
all times i enjoy the moments of it
it gives me satisfaction gives me
happiness um
with that being said i am extremely
persistent my wife my dear wife i've
been with her for 18 years
she is the most amazing things i had in
my life
and we have been together um when i go
at something like share it
for example i started with a research
then we started to fundraise
it will it's not easy none of the steps
are easy there is not a single day that
we don't have a surprise
and persistency and being motivated to
get it through the line and get to the
next step um
i feel it's one of the uh the tools that
are
helping me the most in this journey
michael thank you so so much thank you
thank you for coming on and stay safe
and stay healthy and i look forward to
seeing you
absolutely thank you pleasure